yes I have it all through your social
media presence so Facebook and Twitter
with all nice face yeah MySpace
I don't think we have a myspace Presnell
I love you know so just yes I have not
seen the questions before and so just
but they were solicited and people
participate in its great service to the
fan base of the show so bring it on
okay on Facebook Steve Butler asks do
you know where did he say where he's
from I'm looking on where they're from
he didn't say where he said I'm not
going to guess Detroit Community Butler
it sounds Detroit uh are there any
reasons why a spacecraft would or could
be shaped like a classic flying saucer
in terms of physics or engineering I you
know who's to tell how good aliens are
into branding their hardware but I can
tell you any time I saw flying saucers
in movies started spinning yet the
people in the flying saucer just look
out of a window that has a constant
facing direction yeah I couldn't
reconcile you think they were in a
gyroscope but the inside was still yeah
but everything looked like it was just
right and rotating yeah I know plus
there's some fundamental problems with a
an entire rotating ship if you set it
into rotation something else has to be
sent rotating the opposite direction is
another thing you learn it in the second
week of 50 but if it was made on kepler
22b even because these are laws that
apply to the entire universe and it's
you learned in a second second week of
physics 101 and it's the conservation of
angular momentum so you if you set
something rotating one way something
else has to be rotating the other way in
order to counteract that fact so if for
example if you send a spaceship if you
go into space and you have one of these
space station and rotating wheels where
you simulate gravity if you've got
something rotating one way something
else has to be rotating the other one
the other one to balance it you start
out with nothing rotating two things
rotating in opposite direction
mathematically equals zero rotation
again so you can you have to always
sustain that fact so for saucer to just
spin up and start it I I don't see the
point it's the fact that the whole thing
is spinning that's what your bum has
good one is a propeller and an airplane
your
find that that's just one part of it is
spinning but your problem is the whole
saucer spins and that's what a fool
would build exactly those are the stupid
aliens and and but if they manage to do
that somehow it would be violating very
well tested laws of physics but but you
know also in their defense you've built
very few spaceships that's true and
clearly they have so no the one flaw
other that it probably wouldn't the way
to say this is the laws of physics are
quite commanding or rather quite
descriptive of how because the universe
doesn't obey our laws the laws describe
what we see ran the one of the deepest
laws of physics we know is the
conservation of angular momentum has a
certain amount of a man it never changes
within itself right there's something
from outside of it touches it so I can't
III don't buy it right I don't I don't
and why spin it off I think it's because
when do the frisbee come out it's
probably around the same time
you're right incredible people are like
that must be how it would work it would
be great if you always cut inside the
spaceship it was just a lian's up
against the wall throwing up like that
in the in the amusement park yeah where
the floor falls underneath and and I
wrote about that in one of my books I
think then death by black hole if you
spun fast enough and you so that the
centrifugal force is pushing you against
the back walls if you got sick and had
to throw up the throat would not leave
your mouth would you die or would you
nobody does turn your head sideways if
anyone's a person that can fly up to the
side it's why I only did that right once
as a kid and never again all right